the price of freedom is high
and it's a price i'm willing to pay
lucky you've known me your whole life
you're my best friend on your left
sam wilson steve rogers i kind of put
that together
can you move your seat up no
we need a diversion something big
i'm with you to the end of the line we
got a situation here
what the hell is that everyone's got a
gimmick now
go ahead
[Music]
ah
that was awesome welcome y'all to the
official disney plus launch for
marvel studios the falcon and the winter
soldier i'm angelique crochet
and i'm chenelle berlin johnson from
entertainmentweekly
we are going to be digging into all the
action coming your way with this
incredible new series
launching on disney plus tomorrow friday
march 19th
we're coming at you from the los angeles
air force base in el segundo california
where we are joined by the members of
the space and missile system center
[Applause]
the u.s space force's center of
excellence for acquiring and developing
military space systems
on this base we're surrounded by one of
the greatest concentrations of space
knowledge
anywhere and we are so excited to have
you here with us today
thank you for your service
[Applause]
w we are so excited for this show
earlier this week
we just launched something very special
our new
digital cover
[Music]
[Applause]
and today we're going to hear from the
phenomenal cast and filmmakers behind
this series
to kick things off let's bring in marvel
studios president kevin feige
executive producer nate moore and
co-executive producer zoe nagelhound
[Applause]
[Music]
so i want to jump right on in falcon and
winter soldier have long been fan
favorites in the mcu
and their chemistry together is
undeniable
kevin how did you go about crafting the
concept for the series so you could
explore that dynamic as an unexpected
team
we've been dreaming about it for years
and years ever since we put uh the
amazing
anthony mackey and sebastian standing
together they
had a few scenes together in captain
america the winter soldier did a few
more scenes together in captain america
civil war
and every time we saw those even going
back to before we cut the movie together
just watching the
the footage when we first shot it we
were like these two are great together
would be fun to do a buddy show with
these two
finally thanks to disney plus we get to
have an entire series dedicated to
seeing the two of them
banter love that nate there is an
incredible team behind the scenes on
this one being led in large part by head
writer malcolm spellman
and director kari skoglin what did they
each bring to the series
yeah they brought so much i got to tell
you malcolm is a fan of the comics
and knows a ton about the marvel
cinematic universe he's also an
incredibly talented writer who taught
us about how to mount this show because
we'd only have really done features
but the secret about malcolm is he's
also hysterically funny
so all the humor in the show all of the
mining of that relationship was
something
that malcolm really leaned into and
carrie's an
incredibly talented director who i think
really forced us to ground the show in
character and theme
you know she's really interested in
getting inside these two heroes
that you've seen do amazing things in
the avengers and captain america movies
but she forced us to really get to know
them as people
and really encouraged us to anchor the
show into reality by shooting on
location
by getting really close to the
characters with the camera and
really honestly just directing the heck
out of this show i know i can't wait to
see that balance um
zoe this show does some serious globe
trotting over the course of six episodes
so
how important was it to make sure that
every episode leaves fans feeling like
they have just seen a classic
mcu big blockbuster experience yeah it
was really important to us you know we
went into these shows treating them the
same as the movies
and what we realized the opportunity was
is that we could tell fans a story over
the course of six weeks
instead of just the two-hour experience
in the theater so we hope that each
episode could
leave you wanting more and take you into
new corners of the mcu
in the same way each of our features
does and what's so fun about that is you
get to see
two characters sam and bucky in entirely
new environments you drop them into new
settings where they might be
uncomfortable or have conflict and
that's a really fun you know thing to
explore oh that's so amazing and it must
have been incredible
to be able to do that kevin how do you
think this show is going to take mcu
fans by surprise as it unfolds because
as we know
to expect the unexpected from the mcu
what's fun about the mcu is what's fun
about marvel comics
surprise is right at the heart of
everything marvel's done the comics for
years everything we're trying to do in
the movies and now with these disney
plus series
they're meant to unfold as a
week-to-week adventure we're not quite
sure what's going to happen
each episode and each episode taking you
i hope
to a surprising and unexpected place so
before we let you guys go we would also
love to know what each of you were most
excited to explore in this series nate
let's go ahead and start with you
yeah i'm so excited to explore more
about sam wilkins pass
about who he is outside of the falcon
uniform you know when we met him in
winter soldier steve rogers plucked him
off the street but there's so much to
that character
that we didn't get to explore in those
films that we finally get to
to now yes yes love that zoe what about
you
you know i think it's the opportunity
you know with the time that we have in
these stories to really redefine
characters
to put them in new situations to see
them in
a new light you know for bucky he's
never really had a chance to live his
own life so what is that like for him
and
for a character like sharon carter who
we haven't seen in years
you know what she's been up to who is
she now you know it's this great
opportunity to just
redefine and reintroduce characters
beautiful
uh kevin can you go ahead and finish
this off really it's the size
and scope of the action of this series
that really tapping back
into that action genre from uh captain
america civil war in captain america the
winter soldier
uh it's fun for the mcu to play in this
grounded and gritty action realm
and that's what the series is going to
do i love it well i know we are all so
very excited as well thank you all so
much for being here with us it was great
to talk to you all today
let's hear it for kevin feige nate moore
and zoe negohouse
and now to introduce two men who frankly
need
no introduction let's bring in anthony
mackey and sebastian stan
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to our virtual event
for well
you thank you for having me thank you
so we gotta start by saying you two have
been through a lot
in the mcu but just when some might say
your characters have done it all this
series goes and shows that your stories
are really just beginning so
how was it to reunite for your own epic
adventure
anthony let's start with you oh it was
great you know it's uh sebastian and i
always have fun so
you know reading the script when i saw
what the story was and where our
storyline was going
i was uh really excited to get back
together and
make fun of them some more
that sounds about right um yeah working
with anthony is sort of like getting
into a car without
a break you know
not going to um but uh but that's sort
of the chemistry of the characters and i
think we're both
guided to have fixed towers really
explore their past
uh and go into depth into who they are
now and what their identities
are about i know you can't tell us a lot
but fans have been dying to know more
about what you were really up to for all
those years as the winter soldier so
what surprised you the most about
bucky's journey in the series as he
tries to make peace with his past
um i suppose his sense of humor which
which we sort of had to discover in a
way and that was really exciting and fun
and anthony when fans last saw falcon he
was
being given cap shield like this was a
huge
moment what's sam's mindset going
into this series this series picks up
post blip so you know sam is
really even more so worried about
how does he fit back into society after
being gone for five years
so he's really you know he misses steve
because steve was his friend
steve brought him into all this and he's
um
just wondering how do how do how do they
all move
forward it seems like it's gonna be
incredible but you know what we're not
the only ones who want to know a little
bit about
marvel studios the falcon and the winter
soldier you have
got fans across the globe and they've
got some questions for you as well
our first question comes to us from
brazil
is
so what do your characters have in
common
we'll start off with
that's not true that's not true actually
a lot more than they a lot more than
expected i think a lot more than
everybody expect
100 all right so next we've got a
question from a fan in
group watch what are you watching i'm
star wars
all day every halloween i dress up is
billy d
cause that's what i do so what about you
sebastian
uh i i'm always in the documentary world
which i know is going to get anthony
into making fun of me but
i know i gotta go more lighthearted i
get now i am super excited to get to
welcome a few more folks into the
conversation
emily van camp daniel bruhl and wyatt
russell hello
it is so great to have you all here
good to be here thank you emily and
daniel
fans are so excited to see you back in
your roles as sharon carter and zemo
what was it like to come back into the
mcu emily
amazing as always it's you know so much
fun working with these guys so
um yeah just happy to be back and
excited for everyone to see it
awesome danielle how about you yeah i
was i was so
um thrilled when i got the call um to
come back as simo
um i was in budapest at the time
shooting something else and then a week
later
carrie of scotland the director came
with zemo's mask in her suitcase
so that was a very exciting moment to
put it on for the first time
wonderful emily i love that you've
played some really resilient characters
over the years
what's your favorite part of playing
sharon carter
wow well so many things um i think this
time around though
we see a little bit of a different
sharon which was really exciting
uh we get to see where she's been all
this time after
she sort of made all of these sacrifices
um
and it it was really intriguing to see
this new sort of perspective that she
has
and um and so yeah i mean it's always
fun to do these
these films and these shows and um you
know
to kind of take these characters on
these long journeys and here we are
again and
it's just fun to see a different side of
her i think uh i am so excited to see
that
and wyatt welcome to the mcu for the
first time
[Applause]
thank you we are all
really curious you know what was your
reaction when you found out
that you would be joining the marvel
family it was uh it was
awesome cool and and
who am i playing
we still don't know a ton about your
character john walker going into this
series so
what are you allowed to tell us about
your character and some of the awesome
action coming into the series without
getting yourself into too much trouble
to be honest i don't know how much i
really can
say other than uh it was a blast
filming with everybody and they're great
people and i'm really happy to be with
him on stage again
you clearly have fans all over the world
you guys and
right here at the los angeles air force
base as well so
we thought how about a few questions
from the airmen and guardians here with
us today
my name is sierra moore from the 61st
central engineering logistics squadron
my question to emily and sebastian what
is your favorite marvel memory
well my favorite memory starts with a
kiss
that you had emily because when you kiss
steve rogers
that basically is what started our show
so
so thank you oh there was that
chris evans and then anthony and i
have a steam in the back of a
hi good afternoon i'm second lieutenant
shelby higdon i'm assigned to smc space
enterprise consortium
uh my question is actually for all of
you i would love to know
what is the biggest thing that you hope
people take away from the series
you have six mind-boggling
supercharged hours
ahead of you packed with
um cinematic action pieces
but also with unseen and um
fantastic character pieces what about
you wyatt
i just hope everybody enjoys it now it
has fun watching it
why it's playing it enjoy your life
while you watch
the video uh emily what about you i mean
i i just recently saw it so all i can
say is
it's awesome on so many different levels
you get to
experience these characters on a deeper
level because you have more time with
them
so that's really cool it's also
action-packed super fun
i think it's amazing i'm i'm super
super proud of everyone's work in it the
94th airlift
wing at dobbins air reserve base in
georgia and the 908th airlift wing at
maxwell air force base in alabama were
actually both involved
in this amazing series production from
marvel studios
the falcon and the winter soldier and
they also
sent some questions for our cast i'm
major john t
stom and i'd like to know of all the
avengers cast members
who was the biggest jokester or who had
the best sense of humor
wow that's a really hard question
i feel like we're leaning towards
sebastian saying it was anthony
a hundred percent obviously uh
it's game over all right we have another
question
i'm senior airman karachinsky from the
700th airlift squadron
why do you think so many marvel
characters are veterans that's a great
question
daniel we haven't heard from you from
what i know
and what i always found very interesting
about marvel since the beginning
is that um it was
you know always involved in what was
happening in the world and referring to
what was happening
and always sent messages
to to especially to the younger
generations
which were very important if you think
of world war ii and captain america
he was actually fighting the nazis he
was fighting
fascism so it was a very important
influence of the young people uh
reading these comic books um and
that made me always think that you know
marvel really has a relevance
in its pop culture and that's one of the
things i love about the marvel universe
is that it is relatable
and it does hit on a lot of those topics
all right our next question
hello i am major natalie campos
executive officer of the 94th airlift
wing
what was it like to film on a military
base i
always loved going to military bases to
see what trouble
i can get into because you don't know
all the rules and there's a rule for
everything
so i know i'm going to get in trouble i
just don't know what level of
trouble so it's i just i tried to stay
in my corner
and wave to everyone and not get in too
much trouble
but it's very intimidating obviously you
guys are our favorite duo in the mcu
but i do think we have a few other duos
who want to get in on us on this action
hello anthony sebastian and the entire
cast
of the falcon and winter soldier we are
so excited to see you guys together in
the best marvel team i've ever
well after lizzie and i have cleared the
way for you
what do you mean what do you mean i'm
clear the way
we're still here you know and um
we're still a team yeah i
what do you mean well you know what
happened in the finale
oh no spoilers
hey congratulations guys it's a jeremy
and haley on the set of hawkeye
[Music]
we're sitting here waiting for sam and
bucky to go into action
on falcon winter soldier and uh look
we're here
if you need us for any tips on teamwork
that's right it's all about connections
you know
right finding things you have in common
we have a few things in common don't we
all right we're both into music uh-huh
acting yeah
we do those things like water water
oxygen right
all those things that that we have in
common this is a good team that's right
anyway this is not about us it's not
about we could go on about ourselves and
each other all day that's right that's
not what we're here to do
congratulations congratulations
we cannot wait to see talking with a
soldier can't we check it out
[Applause]
anthony and sebastian in the spirit of
your epic team up
owen and i have decided to unveil the
poster of
our epic team up our new series loki
and here it is
[Music]
that's right we are a powerful duo from
the mcu
marvel cinematic universe just like you
guys equally match
characters in every way working side by
side rowing our ad
you know technically loki's a a god and
you know mobius is kind of more of a
what a bureaucrat should we say
so we don't really mean already equals
true yeah
no no i guess yeah because one of us has
a much bigger ego than the other
yeah i'm sure it's called like
i mean that's what they told me really
i am going to stick by what chanel said
earlier you guys will
always be my favorite mcu duo
this is a real dream team cast across
the board
and honestly it sounds like you all had
a great time
putting this together i hope people take
away from the show that we did not
mess up the marvel brand
this could have went really wrong and we
could have been the first
bad marvel show and we're not we
kept it going
hey we raised the bar man don't stay
yourself
short all right we kept it going baby we
have a good show yes
we're not bad that's what i want people
to say you know what
they don't suck
anthony sebastian emily daniel wyatt we
want to thank you all for taking the
time to join us today
[Applause]
we want to remind everyone to make sure
you tune in tomorrow to catch the first
episode of marvel studios the falcon and
the winter soldier
exclusively streaming on disney plus
trust me you guys you do not want to be
even a moment behind on this one
but before we sign off anthony sebastian
i know you have one more surprise for
everyone
sebastian i think we have a scene here
for you guys
surprise
thank you guys for being here with us
and being such huge fans we have a sneak
peek
of our showboat while marvel studios the
falconetta winter soldier
starts streaming tomorrow exclusively on
disney plus for
everyone watching right here right now
we are going to be giving you a little
sneak peek
so enjoy and thank you for joining us
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i know you have been through a lot
you have no history
no family
so mr barnes are you still having
nightmares
no we've been doing this long enough
that i can tell when you're lying
james people really do want to help you
you've got to maintain friendships
okay okay
sam this has to be subtle
subtle got it
you're welcome
superheroes cannot be allowed to exist
yeah i'm on one can't nobody beat me
down i'm a tall one
is upside down right now
people
[Music]
here we go again huh
so we're partners co-workers not
necessarily a team
we look damn good though
you